this was not normal disruption for north
korea was it doesn't appear to be
according to certain
key experts that we've spoken to about
this outage as you said close to 10
hours that north korea was offline
according to dyn research and they said
look it isn't normal they say they
haven't seen anything like this before
when we're talking to other experts
arbor networks is a security research
company and they said if you look at it
it looks like it was relatively simple
what was going on it was
a simple distributed denial of service
attack now this is basically a kind of
cyber attack
means you get temporary internet outages
you basically flood internet servers
with loads of traffic it ends up
bringing down the infrastructure it
knocks it out temporarily and prevents
websites being able to to track online
but many of these experts are saying
look it's unlikely that this is the
reprisal that the united states has been
saying of course barack obama was just a
couple of days ago that they accused
north korea of being behind the sony
attacks and saying look we will take
measured
action against north korea but many are
saying look this suddenly north korea
going offline would be a bit joke a bit
schoolboy of the us to do because
basically any hacker could do it for
about 200 apparently
maybe you're just annoyed you can't see
the movie and so you tend to attack it
so
you're also not going to really be
wreaking that much havoc on north
korea's cyber attack potential remember
north korea is still saying we have
nothing to do with sony and if you dare
punish us we will come back far harder
remember they were quoted as saying they
will come back thousand times greater if
they were punished well most of north
korea's cyber attacking we understand is
actually done from other outposts
they're not done within north korea
according to the chief scientist at
invincia a security software company so
looks a little bit schoolboy but what we
can understand is also north korea does
have patchy internet it only has four
official networks connecting only very
few computers to the internet in north
korea for mark the u.s has 152 000
networks
so it's probably a country that doesn't
have the most phenomenal access to the
internet and maybe just because we're
all shining a light on it suddenly we'll
get very over excited when there's any
internet troubles whether or not it was
to do with the us the jury is very much
and is china going to help the us
investigate if north korea was involved
in this hacking scandal at sony they are
they have said yes because interestingly
we were talking about this yesterday
weren't we that the china china had been
approached by the united states the
government there we understand
to ask them for help because all of the
telecoms all of the networks supplied to
north korea to get on the internet run
via china they are the telecom equipment
maker for north korea as well and so if
you really want to see what an earth
north korea has been up to potentially
china is a good way to go about it if
indeed they are being rooted via china
and that is certainly what the sony
attack seems to have been rooted via
china so they said yes we will help the
us investigate overalls so
they're acquiescing and i think what's
just so funny
it's not funny it's sort of ironic
basically is that you know back in may
this real tension here between the us
and china it was the u.s accusing
military chinese of stealing secretive
data from companies and now suddenly
they've had to go back to them saying
look would you mind helping us out
actually but it'd be i think actually
setting rather a great precedent for the
two superpowers to be working together